sie sagen wir sind bereits an der
überlastungsgrenze und es sollen die
kommen die Hilfe brauchen und genau wir
möchten Sie ein ganz großen Punkt jetzt
setzen und da möchte ich direkt
reingehen in dem Thema
das Problem grundsätzlich benennen
grundsätzlich benennen heißt dass ich
sage hier in Deutschland wird jeden Tag
das Asylrecht gebrochen was meine ich
damit das Asylrecht ist dafür da zu
entscheiden wer Schutz braucht und wer
nicht und das funktioniert nicht mehr
wir haben eine Anerkennungsquote von
nicht einmal 60% 40% derjenigen die
herkommen völlig unkontrolliert und um
bei dem Gesetzestext zu bleiben
illegal ins Land kommen 40 % müssten das
Land wieder verlassen aber sie haben die
bundesinnenministerin eben gesehen sie
weigert sich sie weigert sich
tatsächlich für Abschiebung zu sorgen
und so auch die Innenminister der
Bundesländer warum weil sie zu große
Hürden erkennen rechtliche Hürden aber
auch in der Stimmung in der Bevölkerung
sie riskieren es nicht das heißt wir
haben inzwischen 300.000 Menschen in
Deutschland die hergekommen sind um Asyl
zu bekommen die es aber nicht zu
bekommen können weil sie nicht
schutzbedürftig sind was folgt daraus
und das ist der letzte Gedanke den ich
hier äußern will daraus folgt dass wir
die Grenzen schließen müssen dann wird
behauptet wir können sie nicht schließen
das stimmt nicht Polen hat die Grenze zu
Weißrussland sehr wohl geschlossen
Bulgarien braucht Geld um eine Mauer zu
Türkei zu bauen und wir wollen alle
keine Mauern wirklich nicht aber was
sollen wir tun was sollen wir tun was
sollen wir tun wenn nur noch die Mauer
hilft und wir anders nicht mehr
unterscheiden können zwischen denen die
Schutz brauchen und denen die keinen
Schutz brauchen dann entwerten wir das
Asylrecht der Bürgermeister hat gesagt
es ist ein hohes Gut aber es wird
entwertet weil hier Leute bleiben
übrigens dann mit derselben sozialen
Grundversorgung wie alle anderen die
hier nicht sein dürften wie stellen Sie
sich das genau in der Umsetzung
forscherte sich Europa damit nicht ab
Mauern soll
selbstverständlich sollte sich Europa ab
und das muss es auch weil
viel zu viele Menschen die auf dieser
Welt leben nach Europa kommen wollen was
ich nachvollziehen kann übrigens ich
weiß nicht ob sie es gesagt haben vorhin
oder jemand anderes ich selber würde es
ja auch tun und die Auswanderung hat
immer so funktioniert übrigens auch dass
die jungen Männer vorausgeschickt wurden
die ihren haben ihre jungen Männer nach
Amerika geschickt das ist nicht die
Frage die Frage ist wie viele Herren sie
haben gesagt wie viele Menschen können
wir aufnehmen und zwar materiell also
finanziell weil ja die Einwanderung
zunächst in die sozialen ähm in diese
Sozialsystem aber auch sozial nehmen wir
ganz kurz noch mal den den Ort weil der
Bürgermeister freundlicherweise heute
hier ist die Menschen müssen das
akzeptieren und die die da jetzt
einquartiert werden nehmen wir mal im im
sag mal im schlimmsten Fall verstehen
mich nicht falsch aber ungünstigsten
Fall sind das alles junge Männer der
meine Güte was wollen die denn die
wollen noch eine Familie gründen die
wollen Arbeit haben die sind doch da
auch völlig verloren das das kann es
nicht sein es ist verantwortungslos es
ist verantwortungslos die Grenze offen
zu lassen ich drehe hier mal den Spieß
um das Schlimmste was wir gerade machen
ist dass wir diese unkontrollierte
Einwanderung weiter zulassen bei Corona
war ja zum Beispiel die Grenze zwischen
Schleswig-Holstein und Niedersachsen
hermetisch abgeriegelt mir kann doch
keiner sagen dass die Grenzen nicht zu
zu machen sind und als dieser
weltwirtschaftlichen bei ihnen war also
ich meine ganz einfach
aber dann geht den halt auch unsere
vielen schönen wahren immer raus ja
rauskommen das heißt die Außengrenzen
müssen geschlossen werden das steht da
drin naja der steht viel in der Welt
also aber die Augen nein Sie können
nicht eine Gesellschaft schaffen in der
die Armut immer größer wird in dem die
Klimakatastrophen größer werden muss ich
die Leute nicht ernähren können und
meinen das hat keine Folgen für uns
sondern man muss natürlich hergehen und
gucken wie in diesen Ländern also wo
geflüchtet wird wie erstens mal Pflege
beendet werden Krieg ist der Hauptgrund
verflucht ja und da haben wir natürlich
machen wir jetzt gerade zwei
Unterschiede zwischen den syrischen und
anderen Flüchtlingen nach Afghanistan
oder sonst wo und den Ukrainern das ist
schon mal nicht in Ordnung ja
aber das sind ja die Bösen und wir sind
die und wir sind die guten aber diesmal
die meiste größte fluchthaus heißt Krieg
also müssen wir endlich aufhören die
ganze Welt aufzurüsten Waffen
nehmen Sie doch mal mein Argument auf
wie viele Menschen können wir aufnehmen
was würden Sie als Bürgermeister dieses
Orgel verlgrenze selber Entschuldigung
ja die liebe Wahlen Parteien ja also
auch die sagen selber wir brauchen
eigentlich eine Zuwanderung von 400.000
Leuten im Jahr in die Sozialsysteme das
weiß ich doch aber die meisten Leute die
geflüchtet sind wollen ja arbeiten das
sagen sie dürfen nicht dürfen keine
Obergrenze nein ich natürlich keine
Obergrenze wir müssen gucken dass wir
die Fluchtursachen beseit igen es geht
hier das ist ja ein ganz schönes
Menschenbild das man sagt okay wir haben
hier ein höheren Wohlstand der ist ja
auch der schultert und es war halt
Mauern Stacheldraht wir bewaffnen uns
und führen den Kampf der Resort haben
eine normale Grenze
sehr spannende es gibt ja den auch immer
weitergeht auch wenn der im Sendungsende
angekommen nach zu uns holen haben wir
hier Kalkutta und Kalkutta auch wir sind
am Sendungsende angekommen und sie
merken schon hier wird noch weiter
wahrscheinlich diskutiert ich will mich
ganz herzlich für meinen Gästen der
bedanken vielen herzlichen Dank auch an
Sie Herr rasieren weiten Weg aus Bayern
angetreten sind um hier zum ersten Mal
in sie gesagt in einer Talkshow zu
sitzen danke dafür wurden sie abgezockt
oder reingelegt
das ist also eine Verzehnfachung das
kann ich Wahnsinn jetzt melden unsere
Reporter kümmern sich um Ihren Fall
kämpft für Sie